political rookie Emmanuel macron is
leading the polls and tip to be Frances
next president a news an organelle give
laughably we before the thirty
nine-year-old meteoric rise has shaken
the political establishment while also
being its last hope
his centrist pro-european open border
views stand in stark contrast to the
rising voices of Europe resurgent
far-right this is how macarons unabashed
ambition drove him from star pupil to
banker to political rebel and now the
hot favorite flee from micron was raised
in the town of Amy on two hours north of
Paris this is the house he grew up in
the eldest of three children from a
family of doctors he attended a judge of
a school precocious kid he preferred the
company of teachers to other pupils and
it was at school that he met his future
wife Bridget Asya was coach of the drama
club they worked closely together to
rewrite a school production he was 16
she was 40 and married with three
children gossip about their relationship
began to spread macron left Nanyang to
finish high school at an elite
establishment in terraced
Causey air followed later to teach and
married a macron 30 after school he
attended University in Paris studying
philosophy then went to the prestigious
National School of administration a
breeding ground for the French elite he
worked for four years as an inspector at
the Ministry of Economy before moving to
the renowned investment bank Rothschild
macron was quickly parachuted into
managing a massive acquisition Nathalie
has agreed to buy Pfizer's infant
nutrition business for almost 12 billion
dollars when the deal went through he
got a big payout
then in 2012 macron was offered a
position working for the new president
and a personal friend francois hollande
two years later alone gave him the
prestigious position of Minister of
Economy he was 36 but by now Orleans
public approval rating had fallen to
historic lows macron threw himself into
a plan to launch an economic regulation
and test the exchanges in Parliament for
up could you justify coming alone but
the reforms were disliked and the
legislation had to be forced through
Parliament sparking violent protests
macron increasingly criticized the
government but still enjoyed the
president's support then last year he
launched his own political movement all
march or on the move thrusting him into
the national spotlight he's really come
out of nowhere you know three years ago
Emmanuel Michel was barely known to the
general public and here yesterday on the
verge of becoming president that's mark
Dean I'm a deputy bureau chief at
Bloomberg News and Paris and I'm on the
campaign trail with Emmanuel macron the
youthful contender was seen as a
presidential longshot when he started
his movement everyone you know including
many journalists including myself fellow
well you know that's pretty cute and
it's a it's a nice effort but you know
he's not going to be President but
borrowing from US President Barack
Obama's election PlayBook took to social
media and ran a large grassroots
campaign in check by the time France
went to the polls for the first round of
voting in April he'd successfully
reinvented himself hello to everyone he
was no longer the failed reformer
working under a failed president but a
new voice in politics but was a see the
Hebrew not optimist cause of Zeus
but courtesy of roof way young on
observer not remove nor canoe hazy home
we can erase you home has some really
fancy yeah I consider a punk he secures
the most votes of any candidate in the
first round putting him into a runoff
with another political outsider
far-right marine lepen still it's not
all smooth sailing into the Elysee
Palace our on has many critics on both
sides of the political spectrum but
against a far-right candidate who wants
to leave the EU will voters on the left
and the right swing behind macron the
answer is that calls currently show that
that is what will happen however you
know this election is not over expansion
is key and anything happened we seeing
with legs appreciable trouble
you
you